but uh there's problems with the audio
because earlier today
there's actually a really big story and
in order this is actually a kind of
hilarious thing we can open with patreon
lawsuit
for those that aren't familiar patreon
is a woke
subscription service yeah where you sign
up
then people can choose to donate to your
patreon i think everybody's at patreon
is for the most part
and there's a lawsuit going on right now
having to do with owen benjamin who's a
comedian who got banned
you know i guess for hate speech or
something and patreon is now
suing his patrons in order to actually
hear the the lawsuit the ongoing lawsuit
i had to download
zoom that was the link it was like join
the meeting right now you had i actually
got to go in the room it was really
funny
because i don't think they realized how
prominent this case was how important it
was there was like 200 people
in this room okay and people weren't
meeting their mics
so the judge was like hold on i've got
to ban this person for you know
oh wow yeah because people didn't like
someone like you'd hear audio looping
and people didn't know
right it was really crazy but uh so i
downloaded zoom zoom broke the drivers
i'm not i'm not saying that to dig or
disrespect zoom i'm just saying that's
what happened yeah
and i guess they tweeted at me like let
us know if you need help but something
happened with the sound drivers it broke
it we had to reinstall it it changed
everything
i i successfully duct taped it all back
together we're using uh we're using a
an xlr splitter to make make it work i'm
actually holding two wires together
underneath the desk the current see it
the audio the current is actually going
through adam it's electrocuting you know
a little bit
well so let's let's do this i want to
briefly talk about this patreon thing
yeah and then we'll dive into the crazy
news once people have a chance to
actually join in
but so uh mike cernovich was tweeting
about this he was in the in the zoom
meeting and i'm i don't wanna i'm not a
lawyer so i could probably get a lot of
the
these details wrong but there's this is
really this is really crazy because
patreon uh patreon banned
owen benjamin his patrons i guess then
filed for like an arbitration because
patreon's terms of service say like any
dispute must be brought to arbitration
not lawsuit or something okay
and then there's this law in california
that says
that patreon has to front the cash
for the overhead costs for arbitration
and patreon realized that
each individual case is it's gonna end
up costing millions of dollars
to go to arbitration it's worse than
just going to court
so they tried getting the arbitra the
arbitration to end i guess and the
arbitra the arbitrator
guy was like no so then they filed a
lawsuit against
owen benjamin's patrons i could be
getting some of the details wrong so i'm
not entirely sure i was just listening
in this court case
but the general idea is that patreon
changed its terms of service at the last
minute because they knew
that these claims would destroy their
company they'd but they call it
irreparable harm but they changed
they changed all those things after they
already went to arbitration right after
so they already took them to arbitration
i mean some people filed for arbitration
okay
and then a bunch of other people filed
later
after patreon changed their terms of
service okay so patrons like oh
but you agreed to the new terms and so
the lawyer for
these patrons was basically like nah you
can't do that right if i agree to an
arbitration clause
and then a conflict arises because of
something you did you can't change the
terms later
right after the future he mentioned a
specific
case that where it's like no the the
terms that will be applied to this
arbitration are the terms from the
creation of the the dispute
like yeah when they actually banned it
right okay
so that means that means basically it
looks like it looks like it's leaning
against patreon
it's going to lean in favor of owen
benjamin's patrons that sounds like a
really good thing
it could be it basically means that all
of these tech companies can be
sued as you know brought to arbitration
and they'll be bankrupted
yeah yeah patreons will be look if this
if this goes through patreon might be
bankrupted overnight
yeah that could just bring them down the
argument is that
i guess i could be wrong about this i'm
not entirely sure it's like a tortious
interference claim
where basically the patrons of owen
benjamin are saying that patreon
interfered with their contract
with owen benjamin because when you sign
up for patreon you're saying i'll give
you five bucks in exchange for what you
offer
by patreon banning this person they
sever the contract between owen benjamin
and the patrons right
which is their argument is towards
interference i don't know i'm not a
lawyer
some of the details i probably got way
wrong all i was do i was listening to
the judge and the lawyers talk about it
but if and there's a thread for mike
czernovich i i r mike started edge i
retweeted it
go to my twitter uh twitter.comcast
check it out because
this could be a seriously game-changing
anti-censorship
ruling yeah like if i don't i don't know
what would happen now because i'm sure
that the courts will try to be
reasonable to patreon
but a lot of people got banned before
these new terms
and didn't know they could do this now
i'm sure the
patreon would argue that's not our fault
you didn't know what to do you know you
can't now sue us a year later under
these you know these rules
but if they argue that patreon
changed their rules because they knew
arbitration was coming yeah i think
every single person banned from patreon
should wh wouldn't you then be able to
have all of those patrons ten thousand
plus people
i was reading about it it seemed like
the judge
was looking at them at patreon and going
why do you think that this is okay what
you did it's not okay
yeah and knowing that it's like it looks
awfully bad for patreon this
you know if i was a lawyer i could
probably give you a better uh i could
definitely give you better there's a lot
better you know individuals than i
yeah but i wonder what would happen if
say like sargon of akan of akkad who got
banned
and he had several thousand patrons all
of a sudden every one of his patrons now
filed for arbitration
saying you know based on the terms
before right
you ban sargon before you change the
terms our dispute is over before you
change the terms
nothing to do with new terms and the
other thing too is i don't know what the
statute of limitations would be
but if many of sargon's patrons
quit patreon they never agreed to the
new terms which means
anybody who canceled their patron
account after they banned even lauren
southern
or or sargon could probably whatever
the time frame might be two years who
knows you know
make an arbitration claim saying you
severed my contract with
sargon and think about this there's a
real there's a real harm there in my
opinion
you had direct access to your favorite
creator to your favorite
political pundit yeah by paying them a
service a fee
right you could then post directly on
things that gave you exclusive access
by them banning him they took away your
ability to communicate with
this higher profile individual that's
hard to reach so that could cause you
you know that's that's you could argue
that's a real damage i don't know if you
can argue actual damages though like how
much money did you lose
right but i think i'm not a lawyer again
so i there's probably a lawyer sitting
there going he's so wrong what a [ __ ]
but i don't know i i guess based on what
i've heard today every
it stands to reason depending on the
statute of limitations if uh
sargon got banned like almost you know a
year and a half ago so it might be too
late but maybe the statute of
limitations is two years i thought it
was like seven years or something for
arbitration overall
i don't know exactly i don't know i
think it i don't know we'll see what
people are saying maybe there's like two
years for
uh for claims in california or something
but imagine what would happen if like 10
000 people went after the social media
company
and said we want an individual
arbitration it would cost patreon
30 million dollars some ridiculous
number they don't have it
no so how and and they'd be spending
every waking moment of their existence
in court
it's their own terms yeah that's true
yeah the lawyer was saying that it's
actually very beneficial to
them so anyway that's the gist of the
story i don't know
you know what else there is to bring up
as far as that goes but this could
change the game of
on on censorship well it's kind of along
the same lines of the reforming 230.
right you know we got we have to look at
the way social media is a platform
that everyone uses it's the new public
space
so patreon is is is the way that funds
the public space
for specific people to reach out to the
community
well they don't know if they if they you
know cancel you essentially cancel you
that's what they did right
they basically this is uh was the reason
they banned him anyway hate speech i
think okay
but this is this is interesting because
i guess it's a tortious interference
argument
okay like i had a contract with this
person and you broke it by banning him
that's weird though because imagine if
like i agree
to you adam to give you five bucks a
month so that i can follow you on
twitter
okay regardless of what twitter offers
me and then if twitter bans you can i
argue that they broke the contract i had
with you
you know what i mean yeah right yeah
like like patreon's core function
is the subscription service so
i don't know the whole thing seems weird
i have the uh definition of tortious
interference right here
it says also known as intentional
interference with the
uh contractual relations in the common
law
of torts occurs when one person
intentionally damages
someone else's contractual or business
relationships
with a third party causing economic harm
hmm i don't know man no idea law speak
yeah yeah i don't know yeah you know i
think i think they might lose but i
think it'll jam up patreon really really
bad
yeah yeah and uh i think they mentioned
that was actually the tactic
that it'll force them to front millions
of dollars whether they have an actual
claim or not
all right it's going to seriously hurt
patreon yeah
well you know don't go around censoring
people
you know we need section 230 reform if
the speech is legal the speech must
remain
yep we can't we can't do it man it's
getting bad and i'll tell you what this
is gonna we're gonna segue in a second
into our main story
but when people get inundated with with
with the same thing
over and over and over again they go
insane but the problem is social media
is really isolating
yep so the people who are on these
platforms
are following very specific bubbles echo
chambers
yup and when the echoes keep hitting
hitting them in the face over and over
again
they keep hearing the same thing
especially when you know when you
you've spoken about this a couple times
we'll go one media
will write something and whether it's
true or not it doesn't matter
it'll enter the echo chamber and it'll
start doing its rounds
right and then the next company will see
it and be like oh
right and one-up it a little bit exactly
and then it continues through
assumptions
and it keeps getting a little bit worse
and a little bit worse and a little bit
worse as it travels through the echo
chamber and by the time it comes back to
the original person
it's probably a brand new story in their
head and they see it and then they see
it
whoa so it'll send it along it'll be
like this they'll see a story that'll
say like
trump's polls drop you know is this the
end question mark right and then they'll
write like wow
things are getting really bad for trump
then someone will see things are getting
really bad and they'll be like
whoa with the bad polls trump could be
really trump could be losing then
someone writes
whoa trump is losing look at the polls
though trump is losing
trump is losing and then it makes it all
the way back to the original guy who
wrote the first story
and it says this is the end for trump
it's game over he goes i knew it gave
him over for trump
see i knew it i called this yesterday
exactly
right and then someone else sees it i
wouldn't i'm surprised you don't
actually get stories where it's like
just really crazy donald trump did a
triple backflip off the roof of the
white house
perfect 10. the olympic committee was
there went nuts purple monkey dishwasher
just like increasingly insane yeah
that's true i guess that shows you
there's like a
thread of of of standards left at these
companies maybe
because like because you think about it
if if someone wrote a story saying like
donald look what they were saying about
donald trump walking down the the the
ramp
i watched the video i was like huh yeah
it's like what if
nothing happened i you know ran
sometimes ramps don't have like uh
grit on them you know like a sandpaper
sometimes they do and if they don't and
it's just a slick surface
i wouldn't want to walk faster did you
fall down did you watch the video i did
he's just walking yeah nothing he's
walking about it
he's it's not walking fast but sure he's
a seven-year-old guy like what are you
excited
i noticed nothing you know spinning and
cocaine
no no no hold on the point is there was
no story at all yeah that's what i said
i pressed play
and nothing happened he wasn't walking
slow he wasn't walking fast
he was just walking down a ramp that's
it i was like and then someone was like
doesn't it look like he's walking slow
and then someone writes he is walking
slow and someone's like what's wrong
with trump is he dying
and then like trump is very sick as
evidenced by his inability to walk
the next one is like trump is bedridden
the next one is like trump must be gone
the drinking water thing do you see that
yeah so someone someone
hit me up with that they're like well
look at this how do you explain that
and i was like well actually it makes
perfect sense look at look at the
sleeves of his suit
so i modeled suits for a long time oh
that explains it and
a lot of the time if the sleeves are too
thin you can't you can't
make this gesture because it bunches up
right so he pushed it and looking at it
that's exactly what happened he like
went and it was like nope and he was
like oh
and then he helped his own you've got to
like push his arm out yeah you know
yeah you have to bring up the extra bits
and like he he didn't he reached down
and went to bring it up and it looks
goofy but it makes perfect sense
you know it's like hello come on it
doesn't even matter because
imagine imagine a world where donald
trump drinks water and it becomes an
international news story
that's how low they they go though you
know what i call it
what scraping the bottom of the barrel
so hard they're pulling up wood chips
yeah that's a good point they're like
yeah and they pull up a chunk of wood
like
i think it's food we got it look so i
like i
look i looked up the definition like the
the the meaning of
the bot scraping the bottom of the
barrel and it was a reference to when
the food was not left yeah you scraped
the edges to get what little bit of food
you could
okay so i'm just imagining like that's
that's my analogy and then i i've
actually gone crazy with it because
i just when you think they can't get any
crazier it's like
they do yeah and so i called it i called
it scraping at the bottom of the barrel
when they complained about trump you
know like
saying a certain thing to a certain
politician yeah then it was like you
know trump's
ice cream and i'm like that's scraping
the bottle at the bottom of the barrel
then it was like
you know trump walking down a ramp and
it's like well they're pulling up wood
chips then it's like trump is drinking
water and i'm like man they're scraping
the bottom of the barrel so hard there's
no bottom left and they're they're
pulling up dirt
yep there's like we found we found more
food down here what is it i don't know
eat it
it's filled with b12 yeah it is
well let's get to the to the main story
everybody if you haven't already make
sure
you uh destroy the like button decimate
it give a little tap
decimated from space decimate means to
reduce by ten percent
okay that just makes sense reduce the
the like button that by ten percent that
doesn't sound as good
i'm i'm pulling hairs though that's kind
of a shame because decimate sounds
awesome that's that's that was the word
that like button i brought that because
i was reading something on reddit where
they were like
decimate is now used colloquially to
refer to like destruction
okay but it was a specific reference to
reduction by 10 percent decimating 10 or
whatever that's funny
so uh anyway yeah but subscribe as well
if you haven't subscribed you really
should
subscribing and liking and uh
notification about you're telling
youtube
you really like us and then when you do
that youtube says maybe other people
will like them
and then shares it so you should smash
that like button basically yeah smash it
and share all that stuff but uh but
interacting with youtube engagement
comments
and super chats because that's how
youtube the algorithm works i guess nice
i don't know exactly how it works
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live
monday through friday at 8pm if you want
to catch the full show
tune in to this channel subscribe hit
the like button or
check us out on itunes and spotify and
we will soon have this podcast up for
free
on all podcast platforms thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next episode
you